[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka die
spd-spitzen ahnten wohl wie das heute
mit genosse schröder in der ersten
instanz ausgehen würde entsprechend
schmallippig gab sich die
parteiprominenz in den letzten tagen ein
parteimitglied
auszuschließen ist nun mal schwierig die
erfahrung hat die spd schon bei thilo
sarrazin gemacht dauerte es mehr als
zehn jahre bis sie ihn los wurde dass
das ziel prozesse sind dafür gibt es
auch gute gründe demokratische
grundsätze und rechtsstaatliche
prinzipien sollen eben auch innerhalb
von parteien gewahrt werden mal eben
jemanden rausschmeißen weil an die nase
nicht mehr passt das geht nicht nun geht
es beim altkanzler um weitaus mehr um
anstand moral und einem krieg aber die
argumente seiner kritiker haben heute
nicht genügt berichtet malik
sie wären ihnen gerne losgeworden hier
in schröders altem ortsverein der spd
hannover oststadt zu gerade sind sie
mitten im landtagswahlkampf die
ständigen anfragen zu ihren
prominentesten mitglied das nervt dass
schröder vorerst in der partei bleibt
damit hatten sie hier fast alle schon
gerechnet ich würde ihm raten sollten
freiwillig das wäre nur ein vorschlag an
die inhaltliche distanz
zur sozialdemokratie die es schon
gewaltig um eine sozialdemokratische
seele die mag das auch nicht mehr was er
so von sich gibt doch die spd sagt
schröder nicht vom hof obwohl die
sozialdemokratische seele leidet unter
seinem engagement für russische
staatskonzern und der fehlenden
distanzierung zu putin ein verstoß gegen
die parteien ordnung konnte schröder
nicht nachgewiesen werden entschied die
schiedskommission des spd unterbezirks
hannover in erster instanz
zitat der antragsgegner stehe mit seinen
äußerungen nicht so weit außerhalb der
programmatik und der grundsätze der spd
dass die partei die sie nicht mehr
ertragen müsse der bereich der
persönlichen freundschaftsbeziehungen
gehöre zum höchst persönlichen bereich
der lebensgestaltung
öffentlich bezieht gerhard schröder
keine stellung er lässt seinen anwalt
sprechen
ich habe keine andere entscheidung
erwartet und bin recht froh dass
innerhalb der partei der spd letztlich
sich vernunft und sachlichkeit
durchgesetzt haben und ich glaube das
ist nicht nur eine gute entscheidung für
die spd sondern es ist auch eine gute
entscheidung für deutschland es sei kein
guter tag für die spd und für ihren
wahlkampf in niedersachsen den
altkanzler nicht aus der partei
auszuschließen kritisiert die opposition
ich hätte erwartet dass man konsequenzen
zieht das man reinen tisch macht
lobbyisten zu sein ist das eine auf der
anderen seite als altkanzler hat man
auch eine gesamtverantwortung für das
ansehen der bundesrepublik deutschland
dem hat er massiv geschadet 17 spd
bezirke wollten schröders ausschluss
doch ein rauswurf aus einer partei ist
ein hohe rechtliche hürden gebunden im
verfahren ging es weniger um moral
sondern ob schröder nachweisbar gegen
grundsätze der spd verstoßen habe das
überrascht mich durchaus denn es gibt ja
auch noch weitere strafen oder
sogenannte sanktionen die man gegen
schröder hätte beschließen können zum
beispiel aussetzen seine mitgliedschaft
dass man sagen ihnen völlig von
jeglicher sanktionen befreit halte ich
schon für überraschend aus sicht von spd
chef lars klingbeil traf die kommission
hannover eine juristische entscheidung
für uns steht fest politisch ist gerhard
schröder mit seinen positionen in der
spd isoliert
ruhe wird erstmal nicht einkehren in die
spd so lange er sich weiterhin ins
tagesaktuelle geschäft einmischt
beobachter in berlin theo koll wie wird
das weitergehen kann dass seine never
ending story werden ja so ist dürfte
jedenfalls eine nicht endende nicht mehr
romanze werden denn die begründung der
schiedsentscheid macht ja sehr deutlich
dass ein erzwungenes beziehungsende sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist die juristischen
chancen für einen ausschuss sind so das
schiedsgericht kaum gegeben es hat nicht
einmal für eine rüge gereicht es wäre
wünschenswert gewesen wenn sich schüler
klarer vom krieg distanziert hätte sagt
das gericht aber selbst der einsatz des
altkanzlers für russische konzerne und
ihre gas und öl exporte sei nicht
parteischädigend im grunde werden
parteien ja immer wieder opfer ihres
eigenen sonderstatus den ihnen das
grundgesetz in artikel 21 einräumt denn
dort wird die wichtige rolle der
parteien bei der politischen
willensbildung betont das heißt aber
gleichzeitig der schutz auch
abweichender meinung ist besonders hoch
jetzt scheint die weitere strategie der
spd zu sein wir trennen uns juristisch
nicht vom kanzler aber zumindest
politisch der spd hat einige baustellen
ja und der altkanzler ist dann sicher
eher das kleinste problem der ampel
steht ja absehbar ein heißer herbst
bevor immer mehr menschen werden jetzt
die hohen energiepreise nicht nur
theoretisch sondern auch sehr spürbar
auf ihren rechnungen erleben und
erleiden die bereitschaft auf weitere
massive entlastungen für den bürger ist
innerhalb der koalition sehr
unterschiedlich ausgeprägt und der
vorrat der drei parteien weitere eigene
tabus zu brechen der kommt an klare
grenzen dazu muss der kanzler jetzt
erneut vor einem parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss zum comex
steuerskandal aussagen fahnder haben in
einem schließfach eines ehemaligen
hamburger spd abgeordneten über 200.000
euro entdeckt auch das kommt er zur
unzeit in niedersachsen stehen
landtagswahlen
der bundestrend in umfrage ist für die
spd alles andere als günstig also der
altkanzler ist eine baustelle aber nicht
die größte dankeschön der einschätzung
sollte sich für lade mir putin für das
parteiausschlussverfahren gegen seinen
freund gerhard schröder interessieren
dürfte er sich einmal mehr darin
bestätigt sehen demokratische
gesellschaft für schwach und
verweichlicht zu halten wenn man es noch
nicht mal schafft ein unliebsames
parteimitglied ruckzuck loszuwerden wie
einfach ist da doch in russland läuft
für querschläger gibt es notfalls
sibirien andere endeten noch in
sichtweite zum kreml mit einer kugel im
kopf aber auch für weniger prominente
oppositionelle ist das in russland so
gefährlich geworden dass ich nur noch
wenige trauen überhaupt kritik zu äußern
an putin oder am krieg der nicht krieg
genannt werden darf für begabte richtung
putin ist ein mörder stand auf einem
ihrer plakate sie belügen euch auf einem
anderen heute verhandelt ein moskauer
gericht über einen facebook post von
marina aufseher nico wie immer werden
wir die imitation eines
gerichtsprozesses zu sehen bekommen
dieses mal weil ich am tag russlands auf
facebook geschrieben habe dass statt die
eigenen probleme zu lösen russland die
häuser der ukraine zerstört während 30
millionen bürger russlands ohne eine
kanalisation dafür aber mit plumpsklos
leben
gleiche stadt anderes gericht hier läuft
der prozess gegen ilja jaschin
wer freiheit für den
oppositionspolitiker fordert wird
abgeführt jaschin nennt russlands
militär operation einen krieg und hat
öffentlich position dagegen bezogen
seine heutige botschaft stoppt den krieg
verpixelt die pressestelle des gerichts
die dieses video zur verfügung stellt
ich zitiere die anklage wenn der prozess
öffentlich zugänglich wäre hätte jaschin
eine plattform für seine anti kriegs
ideen
deswegen muss der prozess geschlossen
bleiben also die staatsanwältin hat das
ausgesprochen was die marionetten aus
putins apparat eben denken
mehr als 3.300 verfahren gab es seit
märz in russland gegen menschen die
frieden für die ukraine fördern einem
von ihnen gilt dieses
geburtstagsständchen
wo selbst blau gelbe turnschuhe schon
zur verhaftung führten wird grün zur
farbe der solidarität mit der ukraine
es gibt hier viele gute menschen die
nichts schlechtes getan haben die unsere
machthaber nicht gewählt haben die gegen
sie sind aber die ganze welt hasst sie
jetzt das ist sehr bitter für mich
doch bezogen auf die größe russland sind
es nur wenige die putins
militäroffensive offen kritisieren sie
stehen der schweigenden mehrheit
gegenüber ein riss auch zwischen jung
und alt
ich lese über diese jungen politischen
gefangenen in meinem alter gibt es da
nur zwei menschen alle anderen sind
höchstens 40 das ist der wahnsinn das
sind unsere vielversprechenden unsere
vernünftigsten unsere korrektesten
unsere freiesten jungen leute
für marina ob sie an ecover endet der
prozess tag mit einem vergleichsweise
milden urteil umgerechnet etwa 650 euro
muss sie zahlen andere kamen für
vorsichtigere proteste schon mal in haft
diese unberechenbarkeit gehört zu
russlands justizsystem zum system putin
sie hinterlässt ein verunsichertes land
atomkraftwerke im kriegsgebiet europa
damit in angst und schrecken zu
versetzen war schon am anfang des
angriffs auf die ukraine teil der
russischen strategie nun spitzt sich am
größten kernkraftwerk der ukraine die
lage zu damit beginnt die nachrichten
von heinz wolf nach dem beschuss des
atomkraftwerks der borussia im süden der
ukraine hat un-generalsekretär ätherisch
darauf gedrängt dass experten der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde
zugang zu der anlage bekommen und jeder
angriff auf ein atomkraftwerk sei eine
selbstmörderische angelegenheit sagte
guterres das atomkraftwerk steht unter
russische kontrolle
das gelände wurde in den vergangenen
tagen mehrfach mit raketen beschossen
die ukraine und russland machen sich
gegenseitig dafür verantwortlich
zur vorbereitung auf einen möglichen
stopp russischer gaslieferungen tritt
morgen der notfallplan der europäischen
union in kraft demnach sollen alle eu
länder ihren gasverbrauch von anfang
august bis märz nächsten jahres
freiwillig um 15 prozent senken
verglichen mit dem
durchschnittsverbrauch der letzten fünf
jahre in diesem zeitraum und in
deutschland wollen mehrere bundesländer
über die notfallpläne mitbestimmen nach
denen hierzulande das gas bei akuter
knappheit verteilt und rationiert würde
so sagte hamburgs erster bürgermeister
tschentscher der welt diese entscheidung
könne nicht allein der bundesnetzagentur
überlassen werden und forderte die
länder einzubeziehen
die seit letzter nacht geltende
waffenruhe im nahen osten scheint
bislang zu halten ägypten hatte zwischen
israel und der terrororganisation
islamischer dschihad vermittelt nach
dreitägigen kämpfen öffnete israel zudem
wieder seine grenzübergänge zum
gazastreifen
im palästinensergebiet konnten schulen
geschäfte und behörden wieder geöffnet
werden
us präsident biden hat die
verabschiedung eines gesetzes durch den
senat begrüßt das massive investitionen
unter anderem in den sozialbereich und
den klimaschutz vorsieht so soll es
allein 370 milliarden dollar zur
förderung von wind und solar technologie
geben das gesetz soll auch die kosten im
gesundheitswesen senken für ende der
woche ist dann die abstimmung im
repräsentantenhaus geplant
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
erklärte heute er habe bei den
herstellern auf einen impfstoff
gedrungen der gegen die derzeit
dominanten subtypen b a 4 und 5 wird
also nicht nur vor schweren verläufen
schützt sondern zu einem gewissen grad
auch vor der ansteckung das hat man ja
nicht mehr funktioniert der neue
angepasste booster soll im oktober
erhältlich sein fragt sich nur ob das
bis dahin nicht auch schon wieder
veraltet ist
geologen waren ja dass bei hohen
infektionszahlen die wahrscheinlichkeit
steigt dass wieder neue varianten
entstehen die sommer welle ist derzeit
jedenfalls in vollem gange auch mit
auswirkungen auf die lage in den
krankenhäusern verena garrett berichtet
sie arbeitet in teilzeit und ist doch am
limit jasmin hahn ist pflegekraft auf
der interdisziplinären intensivstation
der uniklinik homburg die personaldecke
eh schon den urlaubszeit und sommer
welle viele kollegen melden sich krank
wir haben wenig zeit für patienten zu
pflegen haben aber auch wenig zeit um
selbst uns zu erholen oder wir haben
keine zeit oder kein geld um unsere
kinder zu betreuen also es ist ganz ei
ne ganz verzwickte lage wir kümmern uns
immer um alle und erfahren doch so wenig
hilfe auch von der gesellschaft sie
hätten hier platz für 26 patientinnen
und patienten es sind 17 weil es kein
pflegepersonal gibt um sie zu betreiben
steht mehr als die hälfte der betten
leer
wenn ich morgens hier herkomme mein
erster blick ist wer ist krank wer es
ausgefallen welche löcher zu stopfen
dann fängt man an zu telefonieren ich
habe gott sei dank viele teilzeitkräfte
die immer noch ein springen
und so funktioniert im moment das system
es funktioniert aber auf dem rücken der
mitarbeiter ein system auf wackeligen
beinen aber so sind sie bisher durch die
korona zeit gekommen sowie an der
uniklinik ist die situation in vielen
deutschen krankenhäusern personal wird
umgeschichtet operationen verschoben es
ist die erste sommer welle in dieser
pandemie und trotzdem wird weniger
getestet weniger maske getragen sich
weniger gesorgt
wir dürfen nicht vergessen wir haben
jetzt von 500 die es eben 20 mal höher
als das was wir vor einem jahr gesehen
haben das heißt also wir sind auf einem
ganz anderen niveau starten in diesem
herbst und das heißt dass dann wenn die
klimatischen bedingungen sich verändern
und die wirkung nachlässt und
impfbereitschaft sowieso nicht
vorherrscht dass wir dann glaube ich
relativ stark infektionszahlen sehen
werden experten rechnen mit einem
angepassten impfstoff im oktober
basierend auf den aktuellen army konsum
typen b a 4 und 5 viele fragen aber sind
offen und viele deutsche impfmüde ich
könnte mir schon vorstellen dass wir
jetzt noch einmal überlegen wie ist
unsere impfstrategie dass wir da auch
noch mal sehen dass wir im flecken
schließen dazu gehört auch die frage zu
beantworten wer soll eine vierte
bekommen was machen wir mit den
impfstoffen die gegen die neuen
varianten gerichtet sind jasmin hahn
versteht den wunsch nach mehr
leichtigkeit gleichzeitig über blickt
sie mit sorge auf die kommenden monate
wir haben wenig energie jetzt schon
und ich weiß nicht wie wir uns bis zum
herbst erholen um uns gut zu kümmern sie
und ihre kollegen tun was sie können und
was die personalsituation erlaubt hoffen
auf einer nicht allzu hohe welle im
dritten corona herbst
die pandemie hat ja in vielen
weltregionen weitaus verheerendere
wirtschaftliche folgen als bei uns und
dann noch der krieg die ausgebliebenen
getreide lieferungen aus der ukraine
bringen insbesondere afrikanische länder
in schweren notlagen vor diesem
hintergrund wird am dienstag in kenia
gewählt wahlen haben dort in der
vergangenheit schon mehrfach schwerer
unruhen ausgelöst ethnische konflikte
die eskalierten ergebnisse die nicht
anerkannt wurden ganz zu schweigen von
bestechungsvorwürfen
korruption ist nach wie vor eines der
größten probleme des landes auch kenia
gehört zu jenen ländern in denen
regierende reich werden und reiche sich
wahlkampf leisten können unsere aus
afrika korrespondentin susann von
lojewski berichtet warum es diesmal
trotzdem auch zeichen der hoffnung gibt
auch veränderungen
wahlkampf in kenia ist lebendig und vor
allem laut hier auf der insel lamu
hatten immer männer das sagen um roma
will das jetzt ändern die 39 jährige
wirkt sich für das amt des gewinners auf
der kenianischen insel eine art
ministerpräsidentin in ihrem kleinen
büro organisiert sie ihre kampagne dass
sie überhaupt wahr zu kandidieren ist
schon eine revolution
das größte klischee ist dass eine frau
das nicht kann sie kann es nur bis zu
einem gewissen grad das ist das größte
problem in dem moment in dem man aus
seiner box heraus tritt gibt es all
diese mauern mit denen man zu tun hat
im ganzen land bewerben sich frauen auf
politische spitzen posten so viele wie
noch nie die straßen sind mit ihren
plakaten gepflastert sie könnte die
wahlen entscheiden mastercard uhr die
64-jährige will vizepräsident in kenias
werden spitzenjuristen gilt als integer
und nicht korrupt in einem land in dem
viele politiker sich bereichern eine
ausnahme ich denke das ist ein höhepunkt
nicht nur meiner persönlichen reise
sondern unserer kollektiven reise als
frauen die darum kämpfen einen platz am
tisch zu bekommen und dieses mal haben
sie einen platz im höchsten amt in der
präsidentschaft das polit urgestein
raila odinga sie als seine vize
ausgewählt hat ist ein co denn in kenia
spielen volksgruppen bei den wahlen eine
große rolle carola kommt aus der
grössten ist kikuyu lehrer stimmen sind
dem 77 jährigen nun sicher
odinga als größter widersacher der
jetzige vizepräsident mutu der 55
jährige versucht vor allem bei den
sozial schwachen zu pumpen
ich glaube dass ich der kandidat bin der
einen plan hat und fähig ist kenia
voranzubringen
tatsächlich hat nicht zuletzt die
pandemie die sozialen probleme massiv
verschärft stark gestiegene preise
infolge des ukraine krieges sorgen nicht
nur in problemvierteln für große
unzufriedenheit
wir sind es die ihn sagen sollten was
mit uns geschehen soll und nicht sie die
zu uns kommen und uns sagen wir haben da
einen plan auf welcher grundlage
damit ist unseren interessen nicht
gedient
wir die wahlen gewinnt vielleicht auf
eine frage des geldes denn es ist
gängige praxis aller parteien in kenia
bei wahlkampfveranstaltungen geld
auszuteilen und damit stimmen zu kaufen
das ist politik menschen haben
interessen sogar die mit denen du
aufgewachsen bist sind vielleicht mit
der anderen seite verbunden und meist
werden die benutzt schon einmal hat
kenia massenunruhen und tausende tote
nach wahlen erlebt und so hoffen sie
hier vor allem eines dass die wahlen
friedlich verlaufen
und dann blicken wir jetzt noch in eine
andere höchst angespannte weltregion
heinz im konflikt um teil waren bleibt
die situation weiter angespannt china
setzt entgegen vorheriger ankündigungen
seine militärübungen vorteil daran
weiter fort die manöver seien eine
notwendige warnung an die usa und taiwan
sagte ein sprecher des
verteidigungsministeriums in peking die
taiwanesische armee kündigte maßnahmen
gegen simulierte feindliche angriffe
seitens chinas an taiwan will in dieser
woche ebenfalls übungen seiner
streitkräfte durchführen und diese
spannungen führen auch zu
wirtschaftlichen überlegungen stephanie
barron vom ifo-institut gibt es da jetzt
berechnungen zur deutschen wirtschaft ja
ein handelskrieg mit china käme
deutschland immens teuer zu stehen und
würde wohl laut ifo-institut sechsmal so
viel kosten wie der exit größter
verlierer wäre demnach wenig
überraschend die automobilindustrie
gefolgt von unternehmen die transport
ausrüstung herstellen also bauteile etwa
für motoren lieferwagen oder flugzeuge
sowie der maschinenbau china ist derzeit
unser wichtigster handelspartner vor dem
hintergrund des konflikts mit taiwan
wird diese abhängigkeit jedoch zunehmend
ein problem im kriegsfall wäre nämlich
mit internationalen sanktionen gegen
china zu rechnen und die
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen mit
deutschland würden ebenso in frage
gestellt wie jungs die
deutsch-russischen fast 250 milliarden
euro bedruckte im letzten jahr das
handelsvolumen beider länder doch
deutschland ist weitaus stärker auf
china angewiesen als umgekehrt denn fast
die hälfte aller deutschen
industrieunternehmen kommt ohne
chinesische vorprodukte wie etwa
arzneimittel rohstoffe und vor allem
halbleiter nicht aus ersatz müsste im
ernst halb im ernst fall in anderen
ländern teurer beschafft werden das
wiederum würde zunächst unsere preise
treiben und damit auch die inflation
befeuern deshalb rät das ifo institut
zur strategischen partnerschaften und
freihandelsabkommen mit gleichgesinnten
nationen wie den usa ist die allerdings
greifen und lieferketten umgestellt sind
kann es dauern doch das umdenken in
deutschen chefetagen hat längst begonnen
stephanie beckert vielen dank
nach dem rücktritt von patricia
schlesinger als intendantin des
rundfunks berlin brandenburg fordern
medien experten und politiker dass die
vorwürfe gegen schlesinger aufgeklärt
werden es geht dabei um mögliche
vorteilsnahme und untreue
inzwischen ermittelt die berliner
staatsanwaltschaft wegen eines
anfangsverdachts
schlesinger hatte gestern erklärt die
persönlichen angriffe hätten ein ausmaß
angenommen das ist hier unmöglich mache
das amt weiter auszuüben
die britisch australische sängerin und
schauspielerin olivia newton-john ist im
alter von 73 jahren gestorben
das gab ihre familie am abend bekannt
die vierfache grammy preisträgerin
zählte zu den größten stars der 1970 er
und 1980 er jahre die ihren bekanntesten
auftritten gehört die musicalverfilmung
gries gemeinsam mit john travolta
vier tage nach ausbruch eines brandes im
berliner grunewald ist die lage weiter
angespannt die autobahn 115 bleibt zudem
noch gesperrt grund ist laut feuerwehr
die nach wie vor gefährliche lage auf
dem nahegelegenen sprengplatz dort ist
ein lösch roboter gegen die immer wieder
aufflammende glutnester im einsatz wegen
der weiter hohen temperaturen gestehe
explosionsgefahren derzeit lodern noch
kleinere brandherde und es herrschen
hohe temperaturen
wenn alles bleiben soll wie es ist muss
sich alles ändern dieser berühmte satz
aus italiens literaturklassiker der
leopard könnte auch aus dem film stammen
den uns barbara lueg gleich vorstellt im
leopard beschrieb tomasi di lampedusa
wie die welt einer sizilianischen
fürstenfamilie seiner familie durch die
sozialen umwälzungen ende des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts aus den fugen
gerät
so ergeht es auch den protagonisten des
films alcaraz die letzte ernte ebenfalls
seine reale familiengeschichte die aber
in spanien und im hier und jetzt spielt
keine fürsten sondern landwirte die
familie der regisseurin der filme kommt
jetzt uns in die kinos
sommer flirrende hitze die landschaft
steht still
so leise so zärtlich beginnt diese
geschichte der großfamilie soli im
hinterland kataloniens sie bauen für
sicher an
[Musik]
das obst ist ihr leben und es war einst
das leben der regisseurin die für ihren
film auf der diesjährigen berlinale
überraschend den goldenen bären gewann
visum zur iss und der film basiert auf
meiner eigenen familiengeschichte als
mein großvater starb spürte ich dass ich
von diesen menschen in ihrem beruf
erzählen will denn ich dachte was wird
es wohl bedeuten wenn die bäume eines
tages verschwinden
genau das passiert im film familie soli
verliert ihre plantage an den bau einer
photovoltaikanlage und damit ihre
wurzeln und sie verliert auch den
glauben an verlässlichkeit von einst die
offensichtlich nichts mehr wert sind
aber was sie haben wollen ist ein
vertrag aber was soll ich euch sagen
einer unterschriebenen vertrag lasst uns
gibt es nicht da die pille hat mir sein
wort gegeben so wie sein vater meine
der besondere zauber alle die hier so
überzeugend spielen sind laiendarsteller
menschen aus der gegend die die
bedeutung der landschaft fühlen die
wissen wie man für sich richtig anfasst
die hier selbst in großfamilien leben
das schöne an dem film ist dass er zeigt
auch wenn sich die umstände ändern
bewahren wir uns im herzen etwas
wahrhaftiges dieses familiengefühl
können wir konservieren auch wenn wir
alles verlieren
das was wichtig ist bleibt uns erhalten
der film verfügt durch seine sanfte
langsamkeit durch intime studie in einer
großfamilie ihrer konflikte durch gesten
und blicke die so tief erzählen von der
stummen angst zu verlieren was man liebt
team at im film der gebrochene patriarch
kennt im wahren leben die landwirtschaft
seit kindheitstagen
er wollte erst gar nicht mitmachen bei
dieser komischen film sache aber der
obstbauer jordi pujol deutschland hat
eine wichtige botschaft
[Musik]
bauern brauchen einfach mehr anerkennung
ich fand es toll dass das ganze filmteam
gesagt hat sie kaufen nie mehr ein kilo
pfirsiche ohne an die ganze arbeit
dahinter zu denken das essen das wir
ernten braucht mehr wertschätzung
und so ist alcaraz die letzte ernte ein
lebensnah und ergreifender für
eine welt geht hier zu ende aber
irgendwie beginnt auch etwas gutes
warum es endete jetzt erst mal das
heute-journal aber natürlich beginnt
auch gleich etwas neues das montagskino
und um 23 50 gibt es dann unser heutigen
update mit nazan packten das morgen auch
wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die erhitzung setzt sich fort
unter juli 2022 fällt unter die ersten
drei wärmsten juli monate neben 2016 19
und 2022 nun mit diesem monat ja und
ganz besonders interessant über europa
sehen sie hier die abweichungen zu
etliche das schauen wir uns genauer an
und über weiten teilen europas war es
deutlich wärmer als normal und mit den
hitzewellen die von spanien über
frankreich zu uns kam erreichen die
temperaturen knapp 40 grad in
deutschland aber auch in england bis
dato gab es noch nie 40 grad in england
und auch extreme dürre in frankreich so
trocken war es noch nie und das wasser
muss rationiert werden in den alpen
läuft es auf eine rekord
gletscherschmelze hinunter sommer der
läuft noch einige wochen schauen mal ob
da noch regen dazu kommt mit dem hoch
hier das trocknet weiterhin die luft
ausging es nicht in sicht und auch in
der kommenden nacht nicht nach süden und
südwesten ist es sternenklar sonst sind
einige wolken dabei aber da fällt nichts
raus bei temperaturen von neun grad im
vogtland und 16 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet ja und morgen
weiterhin trocken mit viel sonnenschein
im südwesten mehr wolken im norden und
das bei temperaturen bis 32 grad im
südwesten deutschlands und 21 grad
richtung nordsee die kommenden tage
weiteren trocken und in der spitze heiß
weil werten von 32 bis 34 grad am
freitag
ein schöner abend